those joggers trick us every time and I
was tricked I was a victim of the gray
jogger trick I learned it now now I
assessed fully before we take it to so
you couldn't be with somebody who's not
no I'm not gonna waste his time he
doesn't he doesn't deserve it [__]
rich
he will definitely be getting cheated on
on his business trips he might not ever
find out because he's Rich again right
but he will definitely have a very
Unfaithful but loving girlfriend oh
for sure
rich and what it's what if it's the Rock
he will have a very Unfaithful but great
girlfriend at home I feel like it'd be
hard to cheat on the Rock why because
everyone would know you're dating the
rock so it hit the tablets eventually oh
no there's always some Rudy poo [__] in
a corner ready to
it's always one in the corner what if
you what about Michael B Jordan you fall
in love with Michael B Jordan he's a
beautiful man but but it's just I'm not
saying that this is the case because I
would assume with his track record he's
probably doing his thing but let's just
say
hypothetically speaking
that would be hard he would have a
beautiful Unfaithful but great
girlfriend he would never know the level
of my infidelities but there would be
some [__] in the corner probably with
way less than him breaking my back on
the weekends you would jump for the
Hoops to save his heart to make sure he
didn't get his heart yeah he don't
deserve what I would put him through
with that little dick he does not
deserve it but he would definitely
yeah I'm good on it I'm I'm into I like
to be on my person I like that okay yeah
be simple the uh season premiere and
your EP comes out June 16th 13th June
13th yes Amy's World Amy's world is my
world and I'm I'm letting y'all come
into it any features no features on this
one you and Erica Banks are gonna do
anything
watch the season yeah you guys end up
fighting
oh do you guys end up fighting what's
the season it's a lot of the girls
trying to team up and um she's a nice
girl take the talent The Talented girl
out and it's cute and I'm loving it wait
so Erica Banks and you got you guys have
a conflict this this season is there a
conflict
because she watched the season yes I
know but
is given watch the season and you'll
you'll see what's happening here it's a
lot of girls fighting for that position
and the position is mine
and there's a lot of girls fighting for
it and I am who else is rapping on the
show that's a woman
um you have
spice she's an international
um artist spice I've heard of her
you have who else is
uh I was about to be Shady I'm working
on the level of shade that I give so I'm
gonna minimize this about 40 you have uh
Carly Red on there still she's been on
the show for a long time and she's
rapping now okay okay so you have her
and other than that you got some the
guys on the show of course you got
Scrappy you got K.I the keys from Miami
he's a rapper
it's I don't know it's just weird
everybody's like once they got the bag
they just said I actually want to rap
now
it's weird and I'm just there watching
it and just trying to focus on my
situation but it's gonna be an
interesting season so June 13th I
definitely think people are going to
enjoy what they see